MARK MIRCHANDANI: Manufacturing
creates a lot more
than just physical goods.
It also creates a
tremendous amount of data.
Join us as we talk
to Oden technologies
about how they built a
system to help manufacturers
analyze their data using IoT on
this episode of "Stack Chat."
John, thanks so much
for joining us today.
Tell us a little bit more about
what Oden Technologies does.
JOHN TUREK: Mark, thanks
for hosting me today Oden
is a company that focuses
on the internet of things
for the industrial sector
with the specific mission
of improving the efficiency
of the manufacturing process.
For example, we
have customers that
produce $500 million to $1
billion worth of product a year
with high scrap rates.
And by leveraging
the Oden platform,
they're able to reduce, as one
factor, the amount of scrap
material that they create.
In one case, we've
had a customer
that has managed to
reduce their scrap
levels from 23% down to 9% after
implementing the Oden solution.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's great.
So it kind of captures
a lot of data,
and then can somehow relay
that back to the customers.
What does that actual
architecture look like?
JOHN TUREK: A big part
of our architecture
is around managing the data that
we've collected from the users
and making that data
available and actionable.
The starting point
for all of this
is, of course, the
collection of data.
We start with a device that
sits on the factory floor, which
collects data through the PLCs.
That data then gets sent up
to the cloud using Google IoT.
We pull the data off of
Google IoT using Pub/Sub.
We process that
data in real-time.
We run whatever learning models
we have against the data.
We also move the data
over into a time series
database that sits
on top of Bigtable,
as well as into BigQuery.
In addition to collecting
data from the machinery,
we also collect data
from other sources,
for example, the operators
through an operator interface
that we have on
the factory floor.
If a machine is down or
there's a production problem,
the operator will be able to
add data or add annotations
that allows us to then go
back and do further analysis.
And that comes back in
through the cloud as well.
Much of that data then gets
stored into Google SQL.
And we can then pull that data
out as well using BigQuery.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If you
could kind of go back
to when you started,
were there any decisions
that you think you might change?
JOHN TUREK: In hindsight,
there are always decisions
that we would make differently.
One example is our
choice of to use a graph
database to represent
the entities that
sit on the factory floor.
At the time that the
decision was made,
the observation was that
the factory floor does not
follow a strictly
hierarchical model
and the way that you want to
view data on the factory floor
does not follow a strictly
hierarchical model.
You will sometimes want
to organize your data
by factory line.
You will sometimes want
to organize your data
by, for example,
type of machine.
We decided to use a graph
database at the time.
We thought that it would
accelerate our development
efforts, and it did.
However, as we
have scaled up, we
have started to run into the
limitations of that graph,
of the graph database.
One of the areas of
concern is the fact
that graph databases
tend to follow--
be schema-less.
And so what we have found
is that sometimes engineers
will introduce new features.
And because there isn't
a lot of structure,
by introducing new
features, assumptions
that are inherent in the
scheme-less architecture
end up creating
issues down the road.
A second choice that we made
was to use an abstraction layer
on top of Bigtable to support
our time series database.
The choice of Bigtable
has been great.
Bigtable scales wonderfully.
And more recently, Google has
added replication capabilities.
That has been highly beneficial
to our redundancy strategy.
So we feel that we're
much more reliable.
However, at the
time, we had a choice
between a few different
abstraction layers.
And the abstraction
layer that we chose
has reached somewhat of a dead
end in the public community,
which means that it is not being
actively developed or worked
on by others.
And so features that
were missing at the time
remain missing, while
other abstraction layers
have moved forward.
If we were to start again today,
we would probably use TSDB.
And I fully expect that over
the next 12 to 18 months,
we will be making the move to
using TSDB as our abstraction
layer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks so much
for coming in and telling us
about how you kind of built
this architecture to scale.
JOHN TUREK: Thank you
for hosting me today.
And I really enjoyed our chat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Try setting
up your own data pipeline
by using this hands-on solution
that walks through using
Dataflow and BigQuery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching.
And make sure to subscribe
for more great Google Cloud
Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]